hi itself arete again and ya doing some
more road works because everybody lost
roadworks and I just need to do this
there's no way I can get around that see
with everything you do in raleigh co
second three this like there's the fun
stuff and there's the not fun stuff and
path works in no case are ever the fun
stuff at least for me except except for
this little pedestrian area though
because i can add flowers and all that
and if you don't know already i love
flowers it's a it's not very manly i
know but i don't give a I don't give a
crap crap I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't give all of those
profanities I just like to do flowery
things and also the lines on the road to
the the worst thing ever basically also
because I don't even know how American
roads work I know that there was someone
who left a comment saying that I placed
the traffic lights in the wrong
direction they were facing the direction
and like the road that they were
actually on while they should face the
other direction so as a road on the
other side of the crossing if you could
still understand it you'll be able to
see them but I know that in Holland you
actually have the traffic lights on the
road that you're on actually facing you
so you have to look up and basically
break your neck and actually be able to
see what what the light is saying except
you've actually got a stop line and
that's where you have to stop and I
didn't add any stop lines either so I
definitely need to kind of think about
how the traffic works in general and
well back to Rocco second three this is
me making that little square that I want
it in the middle because of course if
you get a high building and nice little
downtown area I just felt like I need a
square somewhere and of course the
bricks that i'm using right now they
look terrible so I'm gonna remove that
later on actually think these look
better so yeah I'm going to replace them
with these steel grey though but I don't
know just this somewhat fans here so
fancy is always good so I'm just going
to go with that also over here and I'm
basically placing a whole lot of these
things over there which makes no sense
because I'm going to place buildings
over there but whatever sometimes I just
do weird things and I can't understand
what I'm doing but it's time for a
building now and actually I'm going to
build many buildings in this episode but
the first one is just going
be a very simple brownish building with
simple things actually this is one of
the buildings of which I found that it
was more theme park ish it definitely
gave away that what I usually do in
roller coaster country is built theme
parks which is probably also thanks to
the fact that it's a very theme park or
some scenery set and I used it in a very
theme park e4 cyan't wait but I don't
even think I can really care about that
maybe it's just some cool building in
the middle of the city which is supposed
to look like this I don't know if that
even makes sense and then there's that
chimney was which was ridiculously high
but i don't know i just really like
messing around with his set I just want
to try different kinds of sets for a
different kinds of buildings so I just
decided that I would give this set a
shot for this building and it didn't
turn out all up all that bad but like i
said it's somewhat theme park ii i'm not
going to remove it because i've already
put work into this and I can't be
bothered to remove anything but it still
looks a bit old-fashioned maybe even in
a slightly Dutch way like something that
would that you would have in some Dutch
area of a theme park and yeah his me
messing with win with windows as always
because it's so hard to get some good
windows the in like the exact windows
because what you have and this is one of
the problems that makes experience to
roller coaster in three players so much
better and faster at the game it's the
fact that at least for me it works like
I get a design in my head I kind of
imagined what I want to create and I
might try to create that in the game by
looking for a custom scenery that kind
of matches what my imaginations come up
with but sometimes you just can't get
the windows that your imagination things
off and I can't be bothered to spend
five hours in Sketchup and the ICT three
import it in make and import all that
stuff so you just have to go through
countless of sets and eventually realize
that there's nothing that you actually
really like and then give up on
everything in life and kill yourself and
that's not really a great thing and I am
moving my hands around like I'm talking
to some audience or something but I am
really not this is just a let's play
what am i doing
and yeah it's time for another building
another building yeah another building
that that makes two buildings already in
this episode and we haven't even started
on the skyscraper yet like holy [ __ ] I'm
doing too much at the same time but
anyway this is just going to be one of
those somewhat generic buildings I just
put this building over here because I
want it to have some building but this
is this building is not going to be too
special as you can see the usual way of
doing things adding a little brick wall
with a little border with some stone
pillars and windows and all that crap
very very standard very generic here's
me trying to add a jewelry sign to that
thing but it not didn't work out very
well and like I actually really like
these awnings though they're one of the
best awnings out there so as you can see
I'm already addicted to them right away
and then try to add them to other
windows but that didn't work out so
screw that and of course one thing that
I forgot is light it's definitely time
for the lights now I messed up I I
messed up with this light so I decided
to go with the park lights anyway even
though they wouldnt they're higher and
they kind of have a better shape than
the other one at least in my opinion so
I'm just going to go with this the only
problem is as you can see I'm having way
too much trouble getting the placement
right because it places like walls ink
at the weird rotation bug so don't
exactly no way that always has to happen
now of course I start working on these
little windows over here and all that
fun stuff and adding that little thingy
try to support it using cornices like
what was even the thought behind that
just just use columns by anyone for
future reference just use columns don't
use cornices to to support something
that makes no no damn sense now of
course I do and a little corners over
there but that's just because I didn't
want to leave the war bear and empty and
actually here this is what I mean with
like that it kind of felt dutch to me
both of these houses because you've got
the dutch pointy roof with the facade
thingy in front and it just felt
somewhat amsterdam ish but of course not
really amsterdam ish because the colors
are too weird for that but it still felt
like that especially considering theme
park sets
and then of course it's time for trees
because trees are awesome trees can make
any terrible to modern looking Street of
a stupid concrete jungle into some
paradise and of course lights with
hanging baskets and flowers flowers once
again flowers they're awesome and I
think at this point oh one more building
great wait yeah one more building after
this so this is going to be the the
awesome glass building that's going to
be great look at that is actually um
this actually felt like a very
commercial building to me at least I
just felt like okay I want to have
something that's facing the the the
crossing because basically you want your
buildings to have one facade where the
which is going to be the main focus of
attention and then you're going to ship
basically also shift or your attention
when it comes to building the building
towards that thing and the rest of the
buildings just gonna be ugly that's
what's gonna happen with this thing
because you have the cool blue thing in
front and the rest of the building is
just white walls with the windows
amazing now I do kind of like this
building though but it's a bit generic
as you can tell by the the the general
shape and everything of it all so it
would seem well I guess more well handy
to have this an entrance instead of some
weird glass eat our thing and yet in
hindsight I probably should have done
that but I I decided to just stick with
this instead so I'm just going to do
this then and as you can see loads of
well attention to all of those little
windows because I don't want to have
okay basically if you use these glass
pings always make sure to add loads of
framework around it because these glass
pings are basically like stucco timbo
walls you definitely need to add some
stuff around it because otherwise it's
going to look too boring and too what
blend in a sense and the main thing that
these windows have going for them is all
that framework I don't know but to me it
just looks aesthetically pleasing and so
does this blue actually I should watch
out when it comes to blue because it's
my favorite color and I tend to overuse
it as
soon as I can so definitely need to
watch out with that but as you can see
this building is actually coming
together very nicely and at some point I
actually felt like yeah I kind of need
to add something to that roof so I ended
that don't know exactly why I did that
but it doesn't really matter anyway it's
time for some simple windows and I added
the entrance to this building while both
doors on the sides which is perhaps a
bit stupid but I just did it anyway and
I try to add some arcs because otherwise
again it would just be bare walls and of
course some nice little trees I don't
know this is just that you can
definitely tell that something is made
by me sometimes because I tend to
overuse the color blue I tend to overuse
trees and as you can see I also tend to
place benches all around the place like
whenever I can I like to place benches
because benches are awesome also not
some point somewhere traffic lights so
that's always cool and no wait no I
totally messed up on that one because
they don't need to face every single
direction they should just face one
direction now something that I do need
to talk about right now is something
that you might have noticed already it's
the fact that I haven't started building
the building yet the skyscraper but
that's going to happen in the next
episode ha ok sorry but next episode I'm
actually going to do it so you can look
forward to that because this is just a
very boring building and I actually
haven't done any skyscrapers yet I'm
actually sorry for that I kind of I
thought I did it in the third episode
but I messed up and actually doing that
I did in a fourth episode I'm actually
going to do it next time though so
what's up for the next episode because I
will actually build the risks first I'm
law skyscraper so see you then guys